[Música]
não é assim mas bruxelas e de resposta
em vôo tem mas que iria submeter de
câmeras um em s
o único negro eo inep atrasou e usar pra
você vai do céu se aplica a conab lucas
gaúcho portugal estaria furioso
milionário suíço nesta britney
possibilita o português que líquido e
essa situação deixa ela ea questão
utilizavam lima sandro alves é do
provedor maloni design que uma mulher
pode ser lido isso ele quer que o nome
do aluno já lhe dá vantagem dobra dós
lei
[Aplausos]
não perceberam nada pois não era
exatamente assim que eu me senti quando
vi para portugal
a primeira coisa que me rodeava era
língua eo não sabiam de começa onde
acaba uma única palavra
toda língua portuguesa parecia uma frase
ah e eu tentava imitar o som da língua à
frente do espelho era qualquer coisa
assim
xuxa grande jogo disse que eles bruno tá
tá tá chique região mexicana julita tatá
lutador aí e tanta coisa engraçada com
essa língua portuguesa
eu lembro me da primeira frase que me se
não meu amigo do ato era isto combóio
para em belém feira em belém
então eu sei da minha casa de linda a
velha até o gerdau já a tentação de
comboios peguei na primeira pessoa
portuguesa e perguntei isso comboio para
em berlim a resposta era xuxa cruzou no
utah
já cristina já tá tá
teve três com boys sabem uma coisa e
quando nós queremos viajar como turistas
viajar e conhecer pessoas diferentes
culturas diferentes técnicas diferentes
e já os vi jogos no fim
voltamos para a nossa casa outra coisa e
quando por alguma razão somos obrigados
a sair do nosso país por causa da
economia faltou dinheiro não é a falta
de estudos alguém de repente somos
obrigados por dentro de uma mala toda
uma vida
será que cada só na taxa
chegamos o portugal 25 de maio 1999
viemos de belgrado sérvia fugimos de
bombardeamentos da nato estão a par de
uma peça de teatro sobre a minha vida
chama vento leste mas não vou poder
apresentar porque dura mais de 50
minutos e pediram para falar só dose em
cada vez
quando me pedem para contar uma coisa e
parte da vida em dois minutos eu entrei
em pânico primeira feliz quando me
pediram isso eu liguei para meu pai e
desaparecer portugueses querem outra vez
que conto tudo que me aconteceu em dois
minutos
como é que eu faço isto e ela respondeu
minha filha como turisticamente vai
suportar isto eu não sei mas vou dar um
conselho a um ponto do discurso é comum
saia da mulher tem que ser
suficientemente curto para chamar a
atenção e suficientemente cumprido para
cobrir o tema
e é esse
estou aqui com dois minutos - senhora
pará e crie uma saia medida certa um
siri de natasha maria noite assim nem
tem de falar de mim falo dela e tudo é
mais fácil começar e natasha marjanovic
no seu 18 de junho 1900 numa pequena
cidade na bósnia herzegovina aos cinco
anos muda para belgrado sérvia e vive em
belgrado até 20 anos vive com o maior
gargalo gada país era engenheiro e um
irmão mais velho dois anos lademir vive
uma vida recheada da morte
além da escola têm aulas extras de
inglês canta no coro dança folclore toca
acordeão acaba o curso de costureira
andam escuteiros
quando aceitamos apaixona se loucamente
por um escuteiro de sarajevo potência
silvina aos 19 anos se inscreva se na
faculdade de direito
isso porque mais chorou toda a noite fã
dela que estudar arte dramática teatro
consequência com 20 anos fica grávida
casa com o escoteiro do cérebro e muda
para a escola superior de teatro de
sarajevo é não ver tá torna ser mãe dos
gêmeos à noite ana
no mesmo ano pela primeira vez na vida
enfrenta ciclo realidade cruel quando
uma funcionária pública pergunta qual é
a sua nacionalidade
a resposta do cempre jugoslava a
funcionar um contínuo no evento serve
croata o botinha a natasha não sabe a
resposta
os meses depois ou seja 6 de abril 92
começa a guerra em sarajevo
bósnia-herzegovina que demora quatro
anos a casa do cérebro leva com cinco
granato em cima na taxa tornassem
modo medo e com toda a família
consiga fugir para a casa dos pais
belgrado sérvia
ao longo de 70 anos em belgrado acaba a
universidade desenvolve vários projetos
de televisão e teatro de bonecos e
animação faz mais de mil festas infantis
e brinca sempre com suas bonecas filhas
à noite ana e 93 irmão wladimir acabou
universidade curso telecomunicações e
decidi tentar as suas
horta em portugal lisboa 96 natasha
recebi o convite do maior centro de
congresso e cultura sala centro de
belgrado para abrir o teatro infantil
maia torna se uma das mais conhecidas
figuras infantis da cidade e 96 é o pai
decidiu vender o apartamento t2 onde
todos viverão felizes durante seis anos
e juntando um dinheiro que lhe custe
apartamentos e casas para todos
o dobro 98 entra em casa nova
24 de março de 1999
sete meses depois começa o
bombardeamento da nato ii
i e ii
[Música]
tá tudo vai
estamos todos aqui dentro do abrigo
nuclear vemos muita cerveja comemos pão
e todas as maneiras
vamos todos sair deste buraco diz que os
mais do que quando entramos aqui há só
para você avisar pra vocês não ficarem
preocupados também a e para vos dizer
elas prometeram que vão atacar só alvos
militar trabalho pesado
i opzz caiu uma bomba numa casa civil
matou destes hoje enganar a mãe mandou
no preto extra que note a meca que
empreende e mais tarde da noite e
princesa e maneca o toeic bridge uma
caixa de banana ona lady
eu dormia lado das minhas filhas em um
mini mai dormir ao lado domingo de pé a
lágrima da minha mãe caiu no meu braço
isto dói mais do que guerra estudou em
mais do que o bombardeamento eu vou
memória chega mas para onde é que nós
vamos conseguir para a rússia tem um
primo lá mas ele está muito frio
posso ir para a espanha seria muito
espanhóis só sei que eu sei
falaram me dando lisboa uma cidade o mar
fica bebendo o vinho como especialidades
marisco não havia guerra tanto tempo
está decidido a mãe não só nos para
portugal a minha maioria é mesmo pai aos
embora
vão ser todos embora vocês acham que ela
em portugal vai encontrar rosas volta
não há mais ninguém neste país
25 de mayo 1999
natasha com os filhos e marido procura
novos palcos na vida chega a portugal a
casa do irmão wladimir em julho 99
enfrenta ser pela primeira vez na vida
olhos nos olhos com uma assessora
trabalhando no bar irlandês como
empregada de mesa
ao longo de 99 conhece há muitos
portugueses criou lindas realizados a
painel um só coração e de portugueses
bebem café consagrada à hora do almoço e
com filas no centro de imigrantes mas
habituou a ser rapidamente entregas e na
totalidade 18 de dezembro 2001 extrai a
primeira peça teatral infantil em
portugal fundado a sua companhia teatro
em 2001 perceber o que é grande a morta
mas não sobreviveu à guerra e fica
sozinha com os dois filhos no meio de
lisboa
escutei volta para bostinha a partir de
2001 começa a trabalhar 25 horas por dia
para conseguir ser mais atriz imigrante
conde gritado realizou muito espetáculos
para crianças e adultos muitas formas as
apresentações animações infiltrações de
intervenções frustrações expressões
extensões e tornou se presidente da
seção cultural palco de chocolate
desenvolveu várias ligações com outras
áreas sociais do projeto projetos que
aproximam a população fora do teatro
teatro de inscrição que a intervenção
prevê que a turquia ter o primeiro que
aprofunde istres tudo
no entanto a maior paixão dela continua
sempre sê teatro para crianças e jovens
no mundo cada vez mais virtual
ela está na desenvolvimento do sorriso
num toco mar no olhar no braço na
palavra viva hoje em 2018 na taxa
encontra-se feliz e e em boa forma
19 anos em portugal se viram para
confirmar tudo que os pais diziam tantas
vezes na vida
humildade é uma das mais belas
características humanas
deus nunca fecha todas as portas sem
deixar uma janela aberta para fim para
podermos ter uma coisa na vida temos de
ter muito mas muito para ofercer isso
prepara-se e faça ao longo da vida
agora eu na tarja na primeira pessoa
desejos muita e muita sorte nesta viagem
pelo vosso tempo nessa viagem pela nossa
vida
obrigada
[Aplausos]